committee holds a hearing on the state
of america's mental health care services
health officials from the obama
administration examine current
challenges
focusing on the relationship between
mental health and gun violence
it's two and a half hours
the committee on senate committee on
health education labor and pensions will
please come to order
my first order of business this morning
is to extend a warm welcome to our
committee's new members
in alphabetical order senator tammy
baldwin
senator chris murphy senator tim scott
and senator elizabeth warren
this is a remarkably talented group of
freshmen senators and we're glad to have
them
on board i know that some are also over
at the hearing on the
senator kerry's hearing on to be
secretary of state starting at the same
time
i also want to salute our new ranking
member senator alexander he has long
been a valuable member of this committee
i've appreciated my relationship with
the former ranking member senator enzi
and look forward to the same kind of
close collaboration partnership with my
good friend senator
lamar alexander today our committee will
examine a range of issues surrounding
mental health care
in this country the tragic shooting in
newtown connecticut last month brought
the issue of mental health care to the
forefront of public dialogue
many people across the nation including
the president have said that we need to
take a long hard look at access to
mental health services across the
country
i'm pleased to have this opportunity
today to start that dialogue with my
colleagues and our panel of expert
witnesses i'm told
this is the first hearing that this
committee this committee of jurisdiction
has had on this issue since 2007 so it's
long overdue
certainly one of the most insidious
stereotypes about people with mental
illness is that they are inherently
violent
i regret that some of the discussion in
the wake of the newtown tragedy has
sadly reinforced this
stereotype as my fellow committee
members know
and our witnesses and experts know
people with mental illness are much more
likely to be the victims of violent
crimes
than they are to be perpetrators of acts
of violence
mental health conditions are sometimes
called the nation's silent epidemic
mental illness affects one in four
americans every year
but despite its prevalence there is
still a stigma attached with mental
illness
and that stigma results in too many
people suffering in silence without
access to the care that
could significantly improve their lives
stigma also can stop workers from
requesting and getting accommodations
and
it can help them be more productive at
work
i've not known so many instances
of people who were afraid to do anything
because
they might lose their job or they
wouldn't get promoted
because of that stigma that's attached
unlike many other chronic diseases
mental health problems often begin at a
young age
experts tell us that half of all mental
illnesses manifest by age 14.
however less than half of children with
an identified mental health illness
receive treatment
and the average lag time from the first
onset of symptoms to receiving treatment
is almost a decade
unfortunately the picture for adults
seeking treatment is not much better
this lack of treatment has huge
consequences some thirty thousand
americans die by suicide each year
it's a shocking fact that people with
serious mental illnesses die
significantly earlier
than americans overall often from
treatable causes like diabetes and
smoking-related chronic conditions
these consequences also spill into other
areas
as any teacher or school counselor will
tell you a child who is struggling with
depression anxiety or
any other mental health condition is
also likely to struggle academically
it's also an issue for our justice
system
since our prisons too often become the
dumping ground for people
you should be receiving mental health
and substance abuse counseling instead
i have had a number of sheriffs
in my own state as well as other states
tell me that the that they're jails
their jails are now the de facto mental
institutions in their states
the shame in this is that with access to
the right treatments and supports
most people with mental illness can
recover and lead productive and healthy
lives
but we need to make the critical
investments that will enable this to
happen
so wearing my other hat as the chairman
of the labor health human services
education
appropriations subcommittee i plan to
take a close look at funding
opportunities in this area
through the appropriations process
we've made important steps forward in
recent years my friends
the late senator paul wellstone and
again along with my friend senator pete
domenici
fought for years to try to enact a
mental health parody act
to end the absurd practice of treating
mental and physical illnesses as two
different things under health insurance
we finally passed that in 2008
however i am sad to say it has been four
years
four years now that we do not have
any final rules on implementing this law
that's a shame i am told the president
said that they will be announcing a
final rule
soon i don't know what soon means but i
hope it means what we generally take it
to me
which means soon
another critical step will take place
next year when thanks to the affordable
care act some 30 million americans will
become eligible for
medicaid or private insurance through
the health care exchanges
coverage of mental health and substance
abuse disorder services is one of the 10
essential benefits required in qualified
health plans
the insurance expansion here offers both
challenges and opportunities
experts predict that the newly insured
population will have a greater need for
mental health coverage than the general
population
as we think about how to meet this need
there's an opportunity to realign our
health care system to better integrate
primary care
and mental health services and in
reading over the testimony last evening
of our witnesses
many of our witnesses spoke about that
this integration
of primary care and mental health
services
i'm this committee i think on both sides
have been very supportive of the
expansion of community health centers
throughout the united states
they've been a great addition they're
they're wonderful primary care
providers but how do we integrate mental
health care services in with those
community health centers
and make sure it's part of primary
primary care
50 years ago president kennedy signed
the community mental health act of 1963
which led to a major shift in mental
health care in this country
people who were warehoused in
institutions moved back into their
communities
but the results were mixed many people
were not able to access the
community-based services and treatments
they need
so as we face major new changes in
healthcare landscape i hope we'll learn
from these lessons
and again as i said see how we might
more fully utilize the community health
center system in america to integrate
primary care
and mental health services so today
we'll hear from a panel of expert
witnesses
who will talk about mental health care
from a variety of perspectives
all with the goal i hope of addressing
this critical but often neglected
public health issue i want to
re-emphasize that my own words public
health issue
so i thank you all for being here look
forward to your testimony
and i'll yield to our ranking member
senator alexander thanks mr chairman
uh thanks for your courtesy i look
forward to working with you we
we've we've worked well together in the
past and this is a
very important committee with a large
justification and i'm
i'm delighted to have a chance to to be
the ranking member
i want to say to senator enzi how much i
appreciate his leadership
and we expect it to continue
um as as as time goes along
um i also want to thank the chairman for
having this hearing and the way the way
he the way he's having the hearing i
mean
we're we're entering this discussion so
far as i'm concerned and
that's my sense of the chairman's
attitude with no agenda other than to
learn what needs to be done
as the chairman said we haven't had a
mental health hearing for a while
and so i'm i i'm i'm here to do a lot of
listening
uh i was saying to some of the witnesses
before the hearing that when i was
united states education secretary i
often was sitting in their
shoes i remember going back and telling
the people in the department that
i thought i was going to a hearing but
in fact it was a talking
because the senators did all the talking
and the witnesses did most of the
listening so i hope this will be more of
a
hearing instead of a talking and i'll
try to do my best
to to make it to make it that way
seems to me that the question before us
is who needs help
and who's there to provide the help we
can hone in on
that question and see what the federal
government can do
to to to to improve
our ability to determine who needs help
and our ability to identify the person
or agency who's who's a job it is to
provide the help then we will have
provided some
some service helps to put a face on
who needs help um as a former governor i
always
look at things from my own background
and perspective as i know most of us do
um about 22 percent of tennesseans
reported having a mental illness last
year that's more than a million
more than a million people this is
according to our state
department of mental health and
substance
of mental health about five percent
uh had a severe mental illness that's
nearly a quarter of a million
tennesseans so that's
that's a lot of people about 41 000
tennesseans had a major depressive
episode uh the funding that
helps meet the needs for that
comes in some part from the federal
government about 22 percent of what
tennessee spends i'm told is
federal dollars the rest is state
dollars
uh in the community uh services
state appropriations are about 70 of the
mental health funds so while the federal
government has a role here
it's a it's a support role and a
supplementary role and it's a role that
ought to make things easier instead of
harder
in preparing for this it seems to me
that putting a face on
the individuals who need help
one group would be a nine-year-old boy
who's
always been pleasant but suddenly
started defying his teachers and his
grades slipped
and he didn't want to go to boy scouts
he didn't want to play with friends and
so they reached out to a pediatrician
who was able
to get some professional assistant he
was diagnosed with a mood disorder
and he began to improve with sleeping
better and so it was a success story for
that nine-year-old boy
another case might be an adolescent a 17
year old
who had no behavioral issues growing up
he started noticing lights in the
bathroom
sounds of water irritated him he had
trouble sleeping
he began to hear voices telling him to
throw rocks
at anyone who told him to come down from
the roof
and he was finally diagnosed with
schizophrenia
but he had but only after he had
multiple episodes those two boys
represent two of the largest groups that
need help and i'll be interested in
finding out from our witnesses
how well we're doing how well we're
doing and helping them
get the help finally i'll be especially
interested
in asking the federal agencies as well
as the state and local
witnesses who are here what can we do at
the federal level to make things
easier to number one identify who needs
help and number two
identify who can provide the help are
there are there
administrative things we can do are
there funding things we can do
are we putting up any roadblocks that
make it harder for you to provide
services if if we are this is the place
to identify them and
see if we can correct them so mr
chairman i look forward to this i thank
you for
for holding the hearing
thank you very much senator alexander
now we'll turn to our witnesses we have
two panels on our first panel
start with pamela s hyde administrator
of the substance abuse and mental health
services administration obviously known
as samsa to all of us
ms hyde was nominated by president obama
confirmed by the u.s senate in november
2009 as the administrator of samsa
she is an attorney comes to samsa with
more than 30 years experience in
management and consulting for public
health care and human service agencies
she has served as a state mental health
director state human services director
city housing and
human services director as well as ceo
of a private non-profit managed
behavioral
health firm as hyde is a member of or
has served as a consultant to many
national organizations including the
john d and catherine t macarthur
foundation
the american college of mental health
administration the president's new
freedom commission on mental health
and the united states department of
justice
our second witness on this panel of
course is no stranger again to this
committee at least to my appropriations
subcommittee anyway
and dr thomas insult who is the director
of the national institute of mental
health and imh
at the national institutes of health
he has been director since the fall of
2002
prior to that dr insult was professor of
psychiatry at
emory university and there he was the
founding director of the center for
behavioral neuroscience one of the
largest science and technology centers
funded
by the national science foundation
he has published over 250 science
scientific articles and four books
including the neurobiology of parental
care in 2003.
he's a member of the institute of
medicine a fellow of the american
college of
neuropsychopharmacology there i said it
and is a recipient of several awards
including the outstanding service award
from the u.s
public health service so we thank you
both for
your backgrounds for what you've uh what
you have done in this whole area of
mental health both in research and
practicality and
your statements we've made a part of the
record in their entirety
i'd ask we'll start with miss hyde i'd
ask if you could sum it up in
five seven eight minutes something like
that and
then we'll get to some questions so
again welcome and aside please proceed
thank you chairman harkin and ranking
member alexander for holding this
hearing today it's an important
day you will hear today about the
prevalence and burden of mental illness
and about the critical needs in our
country for understanding
treatment and support services for those
who experience mental health conditions
samsa's mission is to reduce the impact
of both substance abuse and mental
illness on america's communities and
there's significant overlap between
those two sets of conditions
they currently exist largely outside the
mainstream of american health care
with different histories structures
funding
incentives practitioners and even in
some cases different governing laws
it's time that changed samson envisions
a nation
that understands and acts on the
knowledge that behavioral health is
really essential to health
that mental and emotional health and
freedom from substance abuse and
addiction are necessary for an
individual
a family or community to be healthy
as the senator said almost half of all
americans will experience
symptoms of mental or substance use
disorders in their lifetime
and yet of the over 45 million adults
with any
mental illness in a given year only and
a half percent
of them receive the treatment they need
and of the almost 22 million adults with
substance use disorders only about 11
percent receive the treatment they need
for children and adolescents it's only
about one in five that receive the
treatment they need for diagnosable
mental disorders
cost access and recognition of the
problems are the primary reasons this
treatment is not received
however it doesn't have to be this way
for most of these conditions
prevention works treatment is effective
and people do in fact
recover as senator harkin said the
institute of medicine reported in 2009
that half of adult mental illness
begins before the age of 14 and three
quarters before the age of 24.
we can and must intervene early to
address these issues for our young
people and for our nation
behavioral health is a public health
issue not a social hit
issue and it can be tackled and
addressed in an effective public health
approach driven by data focused on
prevention
and supportive policies and services
that treat and restore to health
i'd like to talk about the affordable
care act for just a minute because it's
going to provide one of the largest
expansions of mental health and
substance abuse coverage in a generation
by helping over 65 million americans
have access to additional behavioral
health benefits
that they do not have now the aca has
already provided screening for
depression
suicide risk and alcohol misuse in many
service programs and in its quality
measures
and it has already provided additional
coverage opportunities for youth
it will ensure that insurance plans
offer in the new marketplaces
cover mental and substance use disorders
at parity with other benefits
and as one of the ten essential health
benefit categories
as part of the president's plan to
protect our children in our communities
he outlined some specific
actions and initiatives to help ensure
adequate coverage of mental health and
addiction services
the administration issued a letter to
state health officials
making it clear that medicaid expansion
plans must comply
with the parity requirements of the
mental health parity and addictions
equity act of 2008
or what we call a pia in addition the
administration will issue final
regulations governing how existing
health plans that offer mental health
and addiction services must cover them
at parity under mapia
the president's initiatives to ensure
students and young adults receive
treatment for mental health issues
include samsa-led proposals such as
a new program called project aware which
would bring together
state officials schools communities
families and youth
to promote safety prevent violence and
identify mental and behavioral health
conditions early
and refer young people to treatment
project aware would also provide mental
health first aid training
a proposed new grant program healthy
transitions would provide a pilot
to model innovative state and
community-based initiatives and
strategies supporting young people
ages 16 to 25. along with hersa
the president's workforce proposal would
provide training for more than five
thousand additional mental health
professionals to serve students
and young adults and finally with the
department of education hhs will soon
launch what we're calling a national
dialogue on mental health
to help change the conversation and
galvanize action about our children's
mental health we've come a long way in
the prevention
treatment and recovery supports for
mental and addictive disorders
but we have a long way to go and we can
do better
thank you for your time today and i'd be
very pleased to answer any questions
that you may have
thank you very much dr hyde and now
we'll turn dr insult please uh
welcome again and please proceed thank
you
mr chairman and linking member alexander
and members of the committee
it's a real honor to be here and it's
actually a great pairing to have
administrator hyde and me on the same
panel this is essentially going from
services to science so as a
person coming to you from the national
institute of mental health and
national institutes of health my role is
really around the research related to
mental illness and thinking about how to
come up with the science
that will lead to better diagnostics
better therapeutics better understanding
of what you called a silent epidemic
senator harkin and that's actually an
interesting term for this
i know we haven't met for some years to
talk about this so it's
particularly for us important to get
this out on the agenda
it's clear that in some ways this is a
response to
uh this tragic event that happened in
december in newtown connecticut
and if it takes an event like that to
focus the nation's attention
on the needs of those with mental
illness uh
it's it's terrible to say that but at
least perhaps one of the
opportunities that can be taken now is
to think about how do we do better by
those with mental illness and how do we
make sure that events like this
don't happen again i'm not going to read
my testimony and to save time i think
both pam and i are eager to get to your
questions but perhaps to preempt some of
those questions let me take just a
couple of minutes to make some of the
points that might
help in terms of how we think about
mental illnesses some of the definitions
and and the science as we understand it
first of all uh when we talk about
mental illness we're talking about as
you
have already heard very common disorders
depression ptsd
eating disorders and there are many
others there are about 10 or 12
that we focus on these are real
illnesses with real treatments
and affect about one in five americans
overall
including youth as we'll say in a moment
today we're probably going to talk
mostly about serious mental illness
that's a term of art
that has to do with those people who are
truly disabled
often by a psychotic illness that occurs
in about overall perhaps one in
20 so it's not quite as common
but it's an important piece of the story
that we need to talk about because these
are the people
who are most severely impaired
as pam mentioned and as already
mentioned by you senator harkin
it's really critical for the committee
to understand that
unlike talking about cancer and diabetes
and heart disease when we talk
about mental illness we're talking about
illnesses that begin
early in life these are in fact the
chronic disorders of young people
and it requires a different mindset when
you think about
how do you detect how do you intervene
how do you make sure
that you can make a difference that's
one of the reasons why these disorders
have the highest
disability rating or the highest
morbidity overall it's because they
start early and they tend to be chronic
as pam mentioned we know these are
treatable disorders
but there's a significant delay in
getting treatment and even in those
young people who have these most severe
illnesses like schizophrenia
on average the delay between the onset
of symptoms and when they get diagnosed
and treated is somewhere between one and
two years
which seems extraordinary because you're
talking about symptoms that are so
disabling
and so obvious and it's especially
unfortunate
because the lesson we have learned from
cancer and heart disease diabetes and
aids
is that the secret to having the best
outcomes
is early detection and early
intervention
that's what biomedical research has
taught us over the last four decades
you have to get there early in the
process if you want people
to have the best outcome and we don't do
that here
and i think one of the things we need to
talk about again going back to your
comment senator alexander about
who needs help and who's going to be
responsible for providing help is why
the delay and how do we do better in
making sure that people get involved
more early
earlier in the process just a comment
about violence
and mental illness because it will come
up i think it's on a lot of people's
minds as you've heard already
most violence has nothing to do with
mental illness and most mental illness
or most people with mental illness are
not violent
in fact we generally worry more about
people with mental illness especially
severe mental illness
being the victims not the perpetrators
of violence and the science
certainly supports that there are two
conditions where we do need to think
about this because violence and mental
illness will intersect and one of those
is these psychotic illnesses like
schizophrenia that start early and
usually adolescents for people who have
not received treatment
they are at greater risk for violence
either because they're
paranoid and may irrationally feel that
they're under attack or sometimes
because of hallucinations or voices
telling them to do something horrific as
you mentioned
with your example example senator
alexander
far more common however is the second
issue is is not
homicide or violence against others it's
violence against the self suicide
is a far more common problem for people
with serious mental illness
38 000 suicides in this country each
year
with the most recent data that we have
that's one more than one every 15
minutes
90 of these involve mental illness
by contrast there are less than 17 000
homicides
with with less than 5 involving mental
illness
so when we talk about violence and
mental illness when we talk about safety
and security when we talk about access
to means our duty to warn the bigger
problem here is suicide
it's protecting the person with mental
illness as well as family members
peers and people in the community
there's a lot that can be done here
we're not great at predicting
it's more still an art than science and
i would say that's true by the way of
heart attack as
cancer as well as serious mental illness
or violence in those people who
are affected by these kinds of illnesses
but even without being 100 certain on
the predictions at the individual level
we can do a lot towards prevention and
you'll hear something about that in the
conversation today
at nih we've really spent much of our
investments
focusing on the earliest stages of
severe mental illness
and identifying high-risk states before
psychosis begins
just the way we do today with cancer and
heart disease and thinking about how
to intervene early so i think i will
stop there except to say that
this is an extraordinary time in terms
of the science of mental illness we are
really in the middle of a revolution
because of what we're learning about the
brain we do think about each of these
disorders
as brain disorders we think about our
interventions in terms of how they
affect
individual brain circuits we've made
tremendous strides over the last 50
years
you cited president kennedy's launching
of the community mental health program
which
actually began with a special comment to
congress on february 5th
1963 so we're almost exactly at the
50-year anniversary
a lot has happened in that time but as
pam mentioned we have a long way to go
and look forward to your questions about
how we can do better going forward
thank you thank you dr insult and i'll
start a round of
five-minute questions um besides i just
want to just again focus
on the mental health party addiction
equity act
signed in law 2008 a major
accomplishment
i'm concerned because the interim final
rule published in 2010
left some implementation details
unresolved
when the administration publishes a
final rule
how will you address issues such as the
scope of services that must be covered
so that insurers
have the detailed guidance they need to
implement the law
um thank you for the question senator
harkin as you
know the interim final rule was
published in 2010
part of what was requested from the
public was input on several topics that
was won
in the meantime we've issued four
or five sub-regulatory guidance
frequently asked questions
we've also been meeting with
stakeholders and with the industry
trying to understand how the
implementation is happening
we are ready to produce a final reg and
we're in that process now
thank you dr insult
i have some concerns and i know others
have also and i've read a lot about
these concerns and i hear them from
constituents and other people who talk
to me
about the use of pharmaceuticals
particularly antipsychotic medications
in children what i hear sometimes a kid
acts up does something
get him a drug get him some
antipsychotic
medication what do we currently know
about the safety and long-term effects
of these drugs in kids
as i've often said children are not just
little adults
they're different and what might work an
adult
even you say well we'll reduce the the
dosage that sometimes doesn't always
correlate
i don't want to practice medicine
without a license but nonetheless
we know that to be a fact what do we
currently know about the safety and
long-term effects of these kids and what
areas require further research and study
well in fact there is a real concern
because the use of antipsychotics in
children has gone up markedly
over the last decade and what we do know
is that children are actually more
sensitive to the side effects
particularly the metabolic side effects
and that's a real concern
because often these drugs are used long
term
so there's an issue there's a real issue
about practice and about
improving the quality of practice in
this regard and i should say that some
of this may be related to
a reluctance for many clinicians to use
antidepressants which are probably
somewhat safer
but there there were concerns about
suicide and actually violent behavior
the curious thing to know here is if you
look at the other side of this
we're not talking about young children
but when we talk about adolescence and
the example that senator alexander used
about
the 15 or 16 year old who's beginning to
hear voices and who's going down this
path of psychosis
what tends to happen most often is not
that people are getting over treated
with medications but that they're not
getting diagnosed and treated at all
and specifically with respect to our
concerns about violent behavior
we know that treatment reduces that that
the most
important thing you can do if you want
to prevent new events like this
the ones that we've often talked about
of the last now
five six years is to ensure that people
who are on this path to becoming
psychotic and paranoid and grandiose and
perhaps dangerous
are treated the risk of violence is
15-fold higher prior to treatment than
it is
after and treatment often does involve
anti-psychotic medication so
it's not the whole treatment but it is a
part of making sure that people who are
developing a psychotic illness are
actually not going to become
a risk to themselves or others we'll
hear a testimony later from
the next panel uh about approaches such
as mind body connections and things like
that
in terms of perhaps especially as it
turns as we get into prevention and we
start recognizing
in young children in school
and other places certain types of
behavior
that maybe early on interventions with
family counseling
and therapy might be more successful
than just
giving them an antipsychotic drug do you
have any comments on that
there are only a few reasons to use an
antipsychotic drug in a young child
probably the most common and the one
that is approved by the fda
is in autism where there are there
are forms of irritability and
what you might call temper tantrums in
which children will hurt themselves or
hurt somebody else
often very young children and in that
case the fda has approved the use of two
different anti-psychotic drugs
to help control that kind of behavior
but for the most part
the medications that are approved for
use in children and the ones that seem
to show the greatest efficacy
are in other classes particularly for
children who have
for instance attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder where the
psychostimulants
have been shown over and over again over
the last four decades
to be not only high efficacy but
high safety as well and we know from
long-term studies that that's that's
helpful
so i wouldn't say that in any of these
cases
medicine is the whole answer but it's
often helpful as part of the answer
there are lots of other kinds of
interventions
that are being developed and some that
still need to be developed
that may be far more effective beyond
medication so this is
just a part of the story thank you very
much doctors
my time is up miss hyde you'd have us i
just was going to say that from a
population-based point of view for young
children there
are interventions not for people who've
been identified with an issue but in
classrooms for example
program that we support called the good
behavior game which has shown fairly
remarkable
ability to help teachers manage
behaviors in classrooms that does have
long-term impacts
thank you senator alexander thanks mr
chairman
um miss hyde it looks like just looking
at
tennessee that maybe a quarter
to a third of the funds that are
available for
mental health and substance abuse
through the state
government are federal dollars does that
sound about right for the
country is that your experience you you
have two big
most of it goes through two big block
grants or one big one and one
smaller one is that is that about right
um
a sort of a rule of thumb is somewhere
around um
a quarter of them funding for the nation
i don't know about tennessee
particularly but is
is for the nation that sounds about it
sounds about
right right if you take the medicaid
dollars
and each state has different
match of course so that changes how much
is state dollars and how much not about
about half the dollars that go for
behavioral health in the country as a
whole
are public dollars federal and state
do you regularly consult with the state
mental health directors about
your two block grants and how they're
administered and
how the money is and how you might
improve the process
of applying for that money and make it
easier for them to help
the people who need help absolutely
senator we
put out a block grant application it's
now a uniform application that
makes it easier for states to apply for
the funding
we go through a public process as well
as informal process of asking for input
from the states
and the two state associations that
represent state agencies
in that process i've heard that the
statutory deadline for the two block
grants is
in the fall september and october but
that you've
indicated that you've moved that up to
the spring
and that's causing some states to have
concern about
about being able to get ready for the
applications because of the legislative
sessions and that some of
and that there's some confusion about uh
how much
information is requested and if as much
as is requested as it appears to be that
it might be burdensome have you heard
that from state directors and if so what
are you doing about that
um thank you senator actually
interestingly enough we
actually changed that date initially in
consultation with some states
what we were trying to do is uh push up
the date so that they could do it
uh their planning during their
legislative process so that as their
legislature decided match
monies or what we call maintenance of
effort monies it could be tied to the
block grant dollars
since the application is not yet out we
probably will change that
date before the final application comes
out
well could i encourage you to to take a
look at that and make sure that
that that it's not a burden on on on the
states and
absolutely and you mentioned the mental
health parity letter that came out uh
earlier this
month did did did the mental health
parody law apply to medicaid as
uh by its terms or or or does it apply
to medicaid
uh by the terms of the new health care
law
or or is the letter something that
expands
the application of mental health parity
to
medicaid the letter just explains
and provides guidance to states about
how mepia
so how the federal law about parity
applies to certain portions of the
medicaid program
so medicaid benchmark plans and
benchmark equivalent plans they're
called or alternative plans
are subject to mapia whereas the basic
underlying medicaid program in the
states
are subject to other laws so it
shouldn't be any surprise to governors
who are evaluating the cost of medicaid
expansion that the mental health parity
law
applies to medicaid um
senator i don't i don't know if it's a
surprise it is in fact uh applies to
certain portions of it so part of the
reason for the letter was to try to
describe the differences about where it
applies
and where it might not yeah um that's
helpful i've heard from a number of
governors who have made decision
about medicaid expansion that it's hard
for them to make that decision without
knowing the added cost of it to the
states as medicaid has grown uh
as a part of state budgets for example
and in our state from eight percent when
i was governor to 26
today so if did you detail in your
letter
what the added cost to the federal
government or states
would be as a result of the application
of mental health parity
to to medicaid
no the letter was not about cost
although as
congress went through the process of
passing the mepia or the mental health
parity
and addictions equity act there was
significant discussion about cost
and all the studies that have occurred
have indicated that the cost is
negligible
and in fact mapia does allow a plan
to request an exemption if their costs
go over a certain amount
so that is part of the appeal law thank
you thank you mr chairman
thank you senator alexander uh now as
you know there's been a
sort of traditional rule of this
committee that
that senator's recognized in order of
appearance and i have here
senator murray and senator enzi we go
back and forth and senator baldwin
frank and murray murphy sanders mikulski
whitehouse
and warren so i would now recognize
senator
murray thank you very much mr chairman
for holding this really important
hearing
and it is i think especially important
to note
obviously the issue of newtown focused
everybody on it but this is an issue
that a lot of us have been working on
for a very long time yourself included
and i think it's
a great time to refocus i think it's
really important that it's your first
hearing and i
appreciate that and senator alexander
welcome you to the new ranking member
position and look forward to working
with you
and all of our new members great to have
you on this committee there's a lot of
great talent here
mr chairman i think that we'll really be
able to do some good things with this
committee
so thank you very much and to both of
our witnesses as well
i did want to go back senator harkin has
mentioned it several times but
in the president's recently released gun
violence package he issued three parity
provisions
one clarifying parity for medicaid
managed care plans
one saying that a parity provision would
be included in the final essential
health benefits rule
and one that committed to issuing the
final rule on the mental health parity
and
addiction equity act which you've
mentioned but it didn't
make clear and you haven't yet made
clear when we're going to actually
see that if these plans are supposed to
go
be ready to go into exchange starting in
october
it's really essential that we see a
final rule on this before april so
let me go back to the question that
senator harkind asked again and ask you
to be specific about
a date that we will see these this final
rule in place
thank you senator murray i think the
president's proposals
indicated that the essential health
benefits rule would be out next month
we are working on the uh parity uh the
mapia
final reg and it will go through the
regulatory process
and uh is in that process now i can't
give you a specific final date but we
are
we see it by april um i can't uh tell
you precisely what the date is but we
are on it now
okay well it is really essential because
our states are working on these
exchanges and they need that clarity
uh to move forward so i can't urge you
strongly enough that
that date is critical um mr chairman one
of the
issues i have focused a lot on in terms
of mental health obviously
is our military families um and i
i just continue to believe we have to do
everything we can for our veterans and
our service members as they
transition especially during difficult
periods of redeployment
and returning home transitioning back
into the civilian world
but those those the focus also has to be
on the families
of these veterans um and i'm certain
that is the same throughout
all of the mental health uh whether
you're talking about uh military or
you're talking about
a number of the other topics you've been
talking about uh the mental health
access act
that that uh that we wrote included
provisions to expand some of the va
mental health
services to family members can you tell
me how
you've been progressing in implementing
the military families initiative
um yes senator we have you may recall
that the president issued an executive
order in the fall
asking hhs and dod and va to
collectively work on improving
the mental health access for service
members and veterans we're actively
working on that
together the three departments part of
the way we're trying to get at
the whole family and the whole needs of
the individual is looking at
partnerships between
community health centers community
mental health centers and va
organizations there are times when
family members
cannot access veterans administration
but they can access
the mental health center down the road
or vice versa
and um so we have been trying to look at
pilots
the executive order called for working
on pilots we're doing that
and we've also been meeting with
stakeholder groups and some of those
stakeholder groups have been families
of veterans service organizations and
others
giving us their input about the best way
we can provide that we
have a report due to the president by
the end of february
so we're actively engaged in that
process okay i'll really look forward to
seeing that and
senator sanders is taking over the
veterans committee and he has a strong
interest in community
health centers as well so i know we'll
continue to be able to push on that but
i think it's really important that we
focus on that for our military families
and dr insell thank you so much for
talking about the importance of
reminding all of us
that mental health health it doesn't
mean that someone is violent
i think that's really important to
remember as we go through this and of
course we do need to focus
on that population that has the
potential to becoming violent
particularly at the younger ages so mr
chairman i think that's why this hearing
is so
essential and i really appreciate and
look forward to hearing the testimony of
the rest of the panels
thank you senator rinsey
thank you mr chairman and uh i want to
congratulate
sunder alexander who gave up a
leadership position on our side in order
to be the ranking member on
this committee and it shows his
dedication to
health and education and workplace
safety and training
and pensions and i know that he'll do an
outstanding job
so and i appreciate you holding this
hearing on mental health as the initial
one
and my first questions for administrator
hyde
i want to know more about the
coordination and collaboration
of agencies at the federal state and
local local 11
level within your appropriate role as a
federal agency
what needs to be done to better enhance
that coordination and collaboration of
agencies at the federal state and local
level
um thank you for that question senator
we've actually been trying very hard to
recognize the relationship
between states and local communities
because the state often will create
laws rules regs that of course the
community has to respond to
so when we provide um grants for example
to our communities we're trying to say
how does this relate to your state's
plan and a direction
likewise when we're providing grants to
our states we're trying to ask how are
you
bringing your communities into that
process so we are by our grant making
trying to bring them together through
our
community block grant application
process we're also asking how
these things relate to what's going on
at the community level
and then we have been providing
significant technical assistance because
there's a lot of change going on in the
health delivery system
to both our states and to our provider
agencies which provide the
basic community infrastructure we also
have
county-based programs that we do a
significant amount of work with so we're
trying to look at those relationships
i personally have had the opportunity to
work at all of these levels city level
county level
state level and now the federal level
and sometimes uh what you
feel is where you sit but i understand
probably
only too well how much those
relationships matter so
we are working on them significantly
thank you and i look forward to any
suggestions you might have
uh dr insel what what do we need to do
to close the gap between research and
real world practice
to ensure that evidence-based treatments
are available in the community service
settings
well thank you it's a question that we
discuss a lot
at nih not just within the mental health
arena but across
all of the diseases for which were
responsible for providing better science
you know the the typical response to
your question or the typical assumption
behind it is that there's a sort of
17-year gap
between a discovery and implementation
and so what we used to talk a lot about
was how do you move
from research to practice interestingly
i say in the last two or three years
there's been a
transformation in how we talk about this
and increasingly we're beginning to say
you know how do we move from practice to
research how do we make sure that we've
developed
not just healthcare systems but learning
healthcare systems healthcare systems
that are
involved in the research process itself
and so at
nih we've created several
efforts to do that involving millions of
patients through large health care
systems like
kaiser and many others in which we are
doing research where we're doing actual
practical trials
in these very large groups a much
reduced cost
but the advantage of that is that you're
making discoveries in the place where
they will be implemented
rather than doing it for instance in an
academic center where there may still be
a gap to getting into the community and
the other piece of that that's so
important
and it's actually part of the new
institute that was formed at nih ncats
is actually bringing in the community
at the get-go and making sure that the
kinds of questions that
are being asked by science or the
going to give you the kinds of answers
that people in the community are looking
for
any reinvention is always appreciated
for
for both of you what type of oversight
or financial controls are in place to
ensure
that federal funding is being used
effectively
to prevent and treat substance abuse use
orders
disorders and mental illnesses what what
needs to be done what changes are needed
i'll start uh we with that question
center we um
for almost all of our programs we uh do
an evaluation
of the program to see what kind of
outcomes we're getting and what the
um what the results are and we try to
use those evaluation results and how we
do the next round of
program activities we also provide some
of the largest amount of
surveillance data in the area of
behavioral health both substance abuse
and mental health
and we're trying increasingly to use
that data to help us understand
where we need to go we're working on
something called the national
quality framework national behavioral
health quality framework which is
a second step from the national quality
strategy that was recalled
for in the affordable care act and in
that we will be laying out
the framework for a quality direction
for behavioral health as a whole
at different levels we also obviously
collect information and data from each
of our grantees and we are
trying to make some improvements in that
by streamlining our
data collection systems so we have
multiple systems now we're trying to put
into
uh one that's uh we hope is more
effective and easier for states to uh
states and communities to report into so
there's a number of activities
that we're going through around
accountability and evaluation and
we work very well with nimh nida and iaa
at the way that their services or the
research that they provide and how we
can bring it into our practices
as well my apologies i've used up more
than my time
uh dr insel would answer that in in
writing and i'll also be
adding a question about duplicative
programs between all agencies
look forward to it thank you senator
enzi
and now senator baldwin welcome to the
committee thank you
mr chairman i am really delighted to
join the committee
and very pleased that the first hearing
in this committee this session is
devoted to this incredibly important
topic
ensuring access to quality and
affordable health care
has been and will always continue to be
a very high priority of mine
and when i say health care i don't
distinguish between
physical health and mental health
because to me they should be viewed as
one and the same the mental health
parity act
and the affordable care act both take
important steps
to make this vision a reality and
together
those two laws will both expand
health care insurance coverage to
millions of previously
uninsured americans and increase access
to mental health care for millions more
who have
health who have health insurance
coverage
so my first question relates to
increased access to insurance coverage
as we speak governors across this
country including in my home state of
wisconsin are grappling with the
decision of whether to
expand medicaid coverage under the
affordable care act
in my home state around 200
000 wisconsinites could gain medicaid
coverage
through the affordable care act medicaid
expansion
should our governor make that decision
so miss hyde i really want to appreciate
the fact that in your testimony you
pointed out that medicaid is currently
the number one payer for mental health
services in the united states we know
that many vulnerable americans do not
currently qualify for
medicaid coverage so in your opinion
how might states that are grappling with
this decision
states that are choosing to expand
medicaid coverage under the affordable
care act
improve mental health outcomes for their
most vulnerable citizens or
perhaps alternatively what variation
might you expect to see
between states that expand
choose to expand medicaid and those that
don't
with regard to treatment of mental
illness
thank you senator and welcome thank you
um
we are very optimistic that as states go
through their processes that they will
come to the decisions to provide the
opportunities for coverage
for their citizens and in that process
obviously each state looks at its um
own medicaid program however the letter
that we just
recently put out was an attempt to try
to help states understand how they
should be looking at mental health and
substance treatment within that
those contexts there are certainly
services that we know can work we're
working
very closely with the medicaid agency so
cms
our partner agency and putting out
informational bulletins on how states
can use their medicaid program to
increase access and to do better for
behavioral health we're working with
them to do that
we also frankly are working on the
enrollment eligibility process
with the department as a whole because
we know that people with behavioral
health needs
typically even after fuller coverage
have a harder time
staying covered so we are doing both
trying to get access to enrollment
eligibility trying to get access through
the type of service or the array of
services
that might be provided and just trying
to provide information to help under
states understand what's the most
effective way to provide
these services the kinds of services
that are most cost effective and most
effective
for treatment thank you
one of the ways that we've already seen
expansion of access to care and you were
talking in your
testimony today about the the barriers
being cost and
access etc
is the provision in the affordable care
act that allows
young people to stay on their parents
health insurance until they're 26.
um something i'm particularly proud of
because i worked very hard on that in
the
house energy and commerce committee and
we're pleased to see it
in the final act uh i'm wondering
i especially given that your testimony
talks a lot about the age of onset of
many
profound mental illnesses being between
16 and 25
whether you're already observing uh
the positive impact of that increased
level of insuredness
for that age population that age cohort
well we certainly know that both the
provision to allow young people to stay
on their parents insurance and also the
provision to
prohibit an exclusion from pre-existing
conditions both help
young people with mental health and
substance abuse disorders
stay on and keep insured or be able to
get
access to insurance when they may not
have access to to it otherwise
millions of young people are covered
through that process already
and we know i don't have a specific
number but we know that those
young people who have these disorders
are part of that group
thank you senator bald senator murkowski
thank you mr chairman and i joined the
rest of my colleagues and thanking you
for
for calling this hearing on an
incredibly important subject
i'm i'm told by my staff that we haven't
had a hearing
uh in the health committee on mental
health issues since 2007
which is which is way past time so
uh thank you for your attention to this
i have been um focused on the issue
of of suicide for for years now and
particularly
youth suicide in this country
in my state we have some very troubling
statistics in in
areas but the one that i find most
disturbing
is our statistics when it comes to to
youth suicide
in the country the rate of of suicide
was 11 and
11.5 suicides per 100 000 people
uh in alaska we're looking at a suicide
rate of exactly double that 21.8
suicides per 100 000 people and even
worse
are our statistics as they relate to our
alaska native young men those between
the ages
of 15 and 24 have the highest suicide
rate of any demographic
in the entire country at a rate of
141 points suicides
per 100 000 people per year and this was
between 2000 and 2009 for us it's
staggering
and it's something that i i just find so
troubling in everything that we do that
we cannot
seem to be making in roads here so
i have long been focused on it i've just
reintroduced along with senator reid
legislation that will will help to
address the youth suicide
and this is the garrett lee smith
memorial act reauthorization we've got a
a good group of co-sponsors on that
but what we're seeking to do is to
provide
a focus on youth suicide in in several
different areas to provide for
prevention programs
and also uh in addition to to providing
these these grants to states and and
tribal organizations but to
to grant to colleges and universities as
well
and the question that i would have uh
for you as as director here is
is how we can do more
within our colleges and within our
universities
to provide for identification
early treatment uh um
early intervention and and the treatment
services that might make a difference
with our young people
in in our universities we we
see these documented mental health needs
i'm concerned that we don't
have sufficient flexibility within the
programs
that currently exist to to help address
this need can you speak to uh your
observations and what we could be doing
better
to to address those in our colleges and
our universities
um senator thank you for the question as
you know that uh surgeon general along
with a very strong public-private
partnership last september put out
surgeon general's national strategy for
suicide prevention and in that strategy
there were several high priority things
identified i
can't have the time nor the memory to go
through all of them at this moment
but there were some very key things like
identifying
even as we've been talking about it in
this youth age group having
raising awareness so people know what to
look for
having people be able to get help better
engaging
after care to use that term so when
people
do have risk of suicide or they make a
suicide
attempt then follow up to make sure that
there's adequate follow-up because we
know that's a high-risk time
providing clinical standards so that
clinicians know how to do the screening
and that includes in campus-based
programs
we're proud to administer the garrett
lee smith program
and we see great results in terms of
raising that awareness
and part of the president's proposals
also include
the idea of a mental health first aid
approach and trying to get people more
aware
especially focused on youth of
what to look for how to get help how to
know someone needs help and how to help
them get that
well i i would hope that we could work
with you on this again this is
this is a key key issue for us dr insa
let me ask you a quick question
it has been noted by my colleague
senator baldwin
that the the identification
of of mental illness
in terms of recognizing um
what we're dealing with onset is as
early as
as age 14 and that the early
identification
can really help with improving outcomes
and yet most of our primary care
providers that are out there
um are probably not adequately prepared
to
uh to identify mental illness at
its its earliest stages uh or provide
for that
appropriate care what what
can be done what is the administration
doing to
support primary care improve these
training opportunities
so that we can do that early
intervention that early
identification it's such an important
question senator because
as we talked about earlier in the
hearing the lesson that we've learned
over and over again
in biomedical research is that early
detection and early intervention
give you the best outcomes so we do need
to do better at this and it's
challenging in this sphere because we do
not have biomarkers the way we do for
heart disease or
cancer or many other diseases where we
can take a blood test and know who has
water who's on the
high risk path to develop something nih
is invested very heavily in developing
just
those kinds of tests whether they're
cognitive
or or biological to know who's in a high
risk state but that's a long-term plan
and and i don't think we can wait to
make sure that there's better awareness
and uh and better community support and
so one of the things that
you heard and pam's already spoken to
this is project aware which was
announced
last week by the president which is an
attempt to go out and increase awareness
in schools in primary care in in
communities about
the challenge that we face the the need
to be able to detect the earliest signs
the same time recognizing that there are
a lot of teenagers who are struggling
and you don't want to
label every one of them as having an
illness so you need to be sensitive to
getting better and better more precise
measures
about who really is at risk and knowing
who to intervene with so
we've got to find the right balance here
and hopefully science will bring us some
better tools for that
my time's expired mr chairman i
apologize i have a gun over thank you
okay and now senator franken uh thank
you mr chairman
i uh like all members of this committee
we thank you for calling
this hearing i want to welcome senator
alexander
as our new ranking member and look
forward to working with you and i i
want to thank senator enzi for his work
as as the ranking member um
like everyone on on this committee i was
devastated by the tragedy in newtown
um and on in the wake of
this tragedy there's been a new focus on
mental health issues
this which i've been working on
for a long time paul wellstone
held the seat that i and i hold and
i too share the sense of urgency about
these the rules on wellstone domenici
being
finalized
while i'm glad we're focusing on mental
health i think it's important not to
stigmatize
people with mental health or generalize
about the connection between mental
illness
and violent behavior i want to thank
both of you for making that very clear
that as ms hyde said in written
testimony most people who are violent do
not have a mental disorder and most
people with mental
mental disorder are not violent and
and dr enzo you said essentially exactly
the same thing
we should make sure that everyone has
access to mental
uh and behavioral health services that
they need
because it will make our communities and
families and them healthier and happier
but again i think it's absolutely vital
that we not
uh stigmatize mental illness in the
process i think it would not only be
counterproductive but counter factual
in the next week i'm going to be
introducing two bills that will expand
access to mental health services i'll be
uh introducing the justice and mental
health collaboration act as really
uh exa reauthorization
of an improvement i hope upon my okra
and this is about
when people with mental health issues
encounter the criminal justice system
and that's it's a very i have seven
republican sponsors on that including
senator hatch on this committee
i'm also going to be introducing the
mental health in schools act which
dovetails with project aware
and this is where dr enzel your
testimony
and and your testimony to ms hyde is so
important and it's about
schools identifying and treating
and giving access to treatment to kids
uh the statistics you mentioned only one
in five
of children who have a mental health
issue
get seen or treated my legislation will
allow schools
to to collaborate with mental health
providers law enforcement
and other community-based organizations
to provide expanded
access to mental health care for their
students it will also
support schools in training staff and
volunteers to spot warning signs and
kids and to refer them to the
appropriate services and
i'm glad that the
you know that project aware it has the
same
kind of focus i want to ask about the
evidence
in terms of
with the caveat that both of you made
about
not stigmatizing mental illness and
associating with violence
that if mental health issues go
untreated
does that increase the chance that
someone with
in a subset a certain subset of a type
of mental
illness will become more violent dr
enzel
or will be a higher chance that they
might become violent
so senator franken within that narrow
band of the people we're talking about
which is a small
small segment of the population of
people with a mental illness
but those for instance who have what we
call first episode psychosis
we know that the duration of untreated
psychosis
is related in fact to the risk for
having a violent act that's been studied
quite carefully and there's
a real correlation there so closing that
gap
is one of the things we can do to
increase safety
so since in in a sense newtown
did prompt this in that very narrow
and and that was one of
a number of horrific occurrences where i
think that no one would question
that in tucson in
newtown we're talking about someone
who's deranged
that had that person
been diagnosed say in school
and had been able to get some kind of
treatment that there is
some kind of connection between
making sure that we're identifying and
treating children
early on with the tragedy that brought
us here
so i'm not going to speculate on those
individual cases because i haven't seen
them but but the data
the published data are quite clear that
the difference between
of severely violent acts like homicide
between
those who are untreated and those who
are treated as 15-fold
so you drop the risk 15-fold with
treatment so it's
it's vital it's absolutely vital that we
detect earlier and intervene earlier
with something that's effective
thank you and thank you mr chairman
thank you senator franklin uh see
senator murphy
is left right now senator sanders
i think uh i think
senator mikulski had a an engagement and
she wanted to ask just one question sir
absolutely thank you very much senator
sanders i have a meeting with
senator shelby to help organize the
appropriations committee
and that will take me thank you
to really the questions for dr enso and
dr
hyde i think what we're hearing today is
that effective intervention
whether it's autism or chronic
schizophrenia
it's research it's treatment and the
workforce to make both happen
so my question to each one of you if we
could just take the issue of
research and then perhaps of workforce
but particularly on research dr insult
what will be the consequences
of sequester on the work at the national
institutes
your national institutes of mental
health
you've talked about this outstanding
work that you're doing
what will happen at this point
what we're looking at is uh about a
6.4 reduction in the 2013 budget and of
course that will come
if it happens uh sometime in march or
april but what are the consequences
uh well there'll be certain studies that
we would like to do that are not going
to be done at that budget and one of the
major projects that we're involved with
is actually highly relevant to this
discussion today which has to do with
how do we ensure that we have the kinds
of predictors
for early psychosis we have a large
national
study in what we call the prodrome that
we would like to scale up
and that's probably not going to be done
if we don't have the funds to expand
what we're currently doing
and so there would be others along those
lines now miss hyde
when one looks at the operation under
your organization
what would be the have consequ
health without mental health
practitioners
which usually goes to training grants
educational grants
actual workforce needs particularly as
you know
at the state and local government would
sequester have any impact
on workforce issues and what would they
be
well senator i think it goes without
saying that we all
um hope that sequester which was never
really intended to happen
doesn't happen um but um
samsa does a lot of technical assistance
and training and we provide a lot of
materials and practice improvement
for the workforce and to the extent that
we
don't have the same number of resources
to do that then less of that will
certainly be able to be done and less of
the grants that we put out as well
so what would have a direct impact on
training
senator very well could we again
we have a fairly uh significant
portfolio in providing
what i call workplace or practice
improvement efforts and that
again includes training technical
assistance materials
just access to the to resources so
um those all take resources to do and um
to the extent that we have the resources
we do it and if we don't then we do
lessons
well i get a picture and we will be
coming back for more detailed questions
on that
but i think it's the this looming threat
is severe
and i'm sure it has a tremendous impact
on morale but
senator sanders yielded his time to me
and
senator sanders i appreciate it i know
you're keenly interested in that
area as well let me just say one word
the reason i asked about the training i
went to graduate school in an nih grant
when this 1963 bill was signed for
mental health
community centers i was a social worker
working as a child abuse worker
because of that at age 27
i was able to go to graduate school and
get a master's in social work
now many might not think and i was
supposed to specialize in community
mental health now many might not think i
have a therapeutic personality
but i did learn a lot and i learned a
lot that these scholarships and so on
make a difference in lives and you have
no unders
the consequences of well-trained people
and what they then produce
in our society i know is important we
hope your training is successful in the
appropriations process as well so thank
you for i intend to be very agitated
about a lot of things
thank you very much mr chairman and
new town and other events have
highlighted
the importance of this issue and i very
much appreciate you're holding this
hearing
let me start off i'm going to approach
the issue in a little bit different way
mr chairman and some of our colleagues
the united states of america is the only
country in the industrialized world that
does not have a national
health care system system
uh in my view in the midst of major
health care crises in this country
including 50 million people
today without any health insurance
hopefully that number will be
significantly reduced under the aca
the reality is that when you don't have
a system you're not prioritizing
so what that means not only
are we not paying adequate attention to
mental health in general
but the disparities based on income
and where you live are also enormous
senator uh murkowski mentioned the
problems in rural
alaska native americans what i can tell
you
and i don't want you to deal with this
for a moment if i'm making
a half a million dollars a year and i'm
living in new york city
and my kid has problems the likelihood
is i'm going to be able to get
reasonably good mental health treatment
for that kid that's the likelihood
for my kid on the other hand if i live
in rural vermont
and i'm making 25 000 a year
you know what i'm gonna have a very
difficult time
accessing the mental health care that my
kids need that's true
i suspect in tennessee and i suspect
that it's true all over
america the reality is right now
that we have a primary health care
system which is a disaster
that whether it is physical illness or
you made the point
that we do well with mental health when
people can access the system
when they need it in my office i can
tell you we get calls in vermont
where family members say i have
my kid my husband serious problems i
can't find
mental health treatment now so let me
ask you a simple question
if our goal is to make sure that mental
health
care is available to all people who need
it
how many thousands and thousands
of mental health practitioners does this
country need and how do we get them
dr insult why don't we start with you
so i'm going to um turn to my colleague
who's just
completing a workforce assessment and so
she's actually looked very carefully
at this issue decide how many thousands
of mental health practitioners do we
need
um we don't have good
studies that say how many we need we
have
lots of data that tell us what we don't
have
and we have lots of data that give us
comparisons between
uh certain areas and certain types of
practitioners
uh we are just completing our report for
congress on that it will be
uh ready so before we even get to the
report
and we need good data tell me
is it fair to say that if i am a
low-income person
living in rural america or urban america
today i am going to have a very
difficult time
finding mental health care for my loved
one
um senator i was actually going to go
right there so thank you for the
question which is
it's not even so much although clearly
in certain areas
of practitioners we don't have enough
but it's also the distribution
the distribution is i come from new
mexico so we have many
major rural areas in new mexico and
there there are
counties in new mexico that don't have
any behavioral health practitioners none
zero we have something like 75 percent
of the psychiatrists are in what we call
the rio grande corridor
which let me guess is probably not
knowing anything about albuquerque
santa fe yes a wealthier area well it's
more urban certainly
yes and where the universities are all
right we don't have a whole lot of time
so my question is
if i am a working class person if i am
unemployed in this country is it a fast
statement to say
especially if i'm living in rural
america that it will be very very hard
for me to access
affordable mental health care in a
timely manner is that a fair statement
um i think it is fair to say that rural
areas have a more difficult time there
are clearly prop
programs like community mental health
centers like community health centers
that have been exposed well i worked
very hard let me just interrupt i'm
sorry i apologize
i worked very hard to double the funding
of community health centers and triple
the funding for the national health
service corps
i think we made progress would you agree
that we need a long long way to go
to expand even beyond where we have gone
in recent years i would agree that we
need more practitioners absolutely
and and i would add to that that it it's
not only across the board but there are
particular areas of need that need
attention one of them is in
children so we've been talking a lot
about youth needs
child psychiatry is a way underemployed
absolutely and child psychology is uh
incredibly important to
build the workforce all right let me
just conclude is
i think it's a class issue too mr
chairman i think to some degree
psychiatry is something that is
accessible for urban
upper income folks it is not accessible
for low-income
rural folks so i think the point that ms
hyde made is an important one we have to
look at geography
and we have to make sure that mental
health is available to all people
regardless of their income
all over this country thank you mr
chairman thank you
i might just add that since i
focus so much on prevention and early
intervention right now school
psychologists
the national average is 1500 to 1.
the recommended ratio i know recommended
by whom
is 700 800 students per psychologist so
we need to double that if we're even
going to meet a recommended level of
for kids in school senator whitehouse
senator warren welcome to the committee
thank you very much
thank you very much
and i also want to apologize for coming
in late
i have the best possible excuse i was
introducing my senior senator senator
kerry
to the senate foreign relations
committee and i
believe that will not be a recurring
event so is that
if that's your way of saying soon you
will be the senior senator from
massachusetts
yes sir it is
so i i thank you i would like to start
with my questions
in the same place that senator enzi
started i have
a very similar interest in the question
about
questions about research uh around
evidence-based medicine
around accountability around our funding
for research
so what i'd like to do is just start
with you dr insel
if you would and ask you to do two
things for us
the first is just paint us a little bit
of a picture
about what we can do with research in
the mental health field
if we get some good research what can we
learn that we don't know
and to talk just a little bit about what
funding levels
are doing to research
thank you for that question i don't
usually get an opportunity to
talk about this and i promise i'll do it
very quickly um but
but you're asking the question at a
critical moment in
in time we are really in the case of
understanding mental illness where we
were in some ways
for study cancer 20 or 30 years ago
we're just on the cusp of a revolution
and it's because we have these
extraordinary tools now
and for the first time we can approach
problems of the mind through studying
the brain and that gives us a kind of
precision
that we've never even imagined we could
have
the reason that's so important is
because for behavioral problems whether
they're in
parkinson's disease or alzheimer's
disease or huntington's disease
the behavioral symptoms are a very late
event those are the heart attacks and
it's the same thing we believe
for the psychosis in schizophrenia
we define these as behavioral disorders
but in fact
they're brain disorders and the brain
changes are probably occurring
years earlier and if we want to detect
and
intervene earlier we're going to have to
be able to develop ways to
to get at that to understand them as
brain disorders in the same way that
we've done now
in many other areas of medicine so i
think
where the science is taking us is
towards the biomarkers that's towards
the fundamental biology we have not been
there before we've had a very simplistic
approach to this
it is far more complicated the good news
is we've got
far better tools to be able to unpack
this
your question was about the funding
it's it's a challenge there are lots of
questions
lots of things we'd like to answer i'd
have to say that for nimh the shift has
largely been
to move much of our funding to people
who actually 10 years ago were studying
cancer and heart disease
who are now joining us because they feel
that autism and schizophrenia
are the new frontiers and these are the
places where you're going to make the
big breakthroughs
it's always frustrating because there's
of course never enough
funding to support all the best ideas
that come in
we try to support about 20 of them so
about one in five grants gets funded
i hope that i'm smart enough to pick the
best 20 i'm afraid i'm not
and i think if i could do 30 percent i'd
probably have a much
better hit rate it's just hard to know
often so
that's always the challenge is you never
have the funding you want to do all the
science
some of what which is just spectacular
that's sitting there in front of you
can i ask you just to expand on that in
one more dimension
and that is if you you describe it as
your hit rate
if you really hit on some of these
studies on alzheimer's
on autism can you just speak briefly
about what the financial impact will be
on the country well so we know that in
the case of
alzheimer's that if we can just
forestall
the dementia by a matter of a year
or two years which is certainly i think
within our grasp as we've
gotten a better understanding of how to
predict and now looking at ways to
intervene
we're talking about billions of dollars
that will not have to be spent
which are now being going into into the
care of people with dementia
it really comes down to a question of do
do you want to invest
early or do you want to pay later
because you don't know enough and you're
not doing this in a way that's efficient
and unfortunately i think we've tended
to decide that we'll pay later often at
a very large premium instead of making
the early investments in
alzheimer's autism schizophrenia to make
sure that we
come up with better solutions thank you
very much
miss hyde my time has expired but if you
had a quick comment you'd like to add
the quick comment here is we you know of
course that these
uh disorders have profound impacts on
our justice systems
on our school systems on our public
welfare systems our child welfare
systems
there's profound dollars that are being
spent there because we're not
intervening early
because we are not providing the kind of
supports to the to the young people and
their families
thank you very much thank you mr
chairman
mr chairman thank you i was
unfortunately on the floor
um with my senior senator there's
nothing unfortunate about that on an
issue of great importance to colorado
so i missed the testimony i think i'll
refrain from asking my questions today
and i'll submit some for the record if
that's okay with you
and i know there's a second panel but i
want to thank you
very much for holding this hearing and i
and i also i'd like to join
uh senator franklin and in saying how
delighted i am to see our ranking member
senator alexander here and
um and thank senator enzi also for his
work as the ranking member of the
committee and finally
to welcome uh our new colleagues to the
committee
it's wonderful to see you here thank you
mr chairman
thank you senator bennett i thank our
first panel thank you dr insult thank
you miss hyde for
being here now we'll call our second
panel
uh dr michael hogan dr robert vero
mr george delgrosso and mr larry fricks
let me see which one is
so our next panel uh first i'll
introduce michael hogan dr hogan the
former commissioner of the new york
state office of mental health
and chairman of the president's new
freedom commission on mental health
in his capacity as commissioner of the
new york state mental health office he
oversaw new york's five billion dollar
public mental health system
previously he served as director of the
ohio department of mental health
and commissioner of the connecticut
department of mental health so we thank
you for
being here dr hogan and for purposes of
introduction now i'll
turn to our ranking member senator
alexander thanks mr chairman i'm
i'm delighted to welcome robert vero
from
center stone of of tennessee he's well
known in our state
he's he's done work in the behavioral
health care field for a long time
four decades uh he's chief executive of
a
of a company or a non-profit
organization the largest non-profit
community mental health centers
uh they have more than 50 facilities 160
partnership
locations they serve nearly 50 000
people of all ages
each year he has distinguished academic
background which includes his work at
peabody college at vanderbilt he's a
clinician
he's active and consulted
by many for his expertise in this field
and i look forward
to his insights about who
needs help and how we can do a better
job of
making sure they get that help so thank
you for being here dr vero
thank you senator alexander and also for
personal introduction i recognize the
senator from
colorado senator ben thank you mr
chairman it is a great privilege to
introduce mr george del grosso to the
committee
mr del grosso currently serves as the
chief executive officer of the colorado
behavioral health care council the
council is a statewide network
comprising 28
behavioral health organizations it
provides treatment and other services to
over
a hundred and twenty thousand coloradans
each year
mr delgrossa began his career as a
psychotherapist he then
became a marriage and family therapist
he was promoted to a clinical supervisor
and program developer before
ultimately moving into senior management
before leading the colorado behavioral
health care council mr delgrosso served
as
the executive director of mental health
centers in the san luis valley
in our state and in cody wyoming
throughout his career mr delgrosso has
worked to improve training and to
develop integrated
treatment approaches to mental health
care currently
he's working to expand the mental health
first aid program in colorado to improve
prevention early identification and
access to health
to care for those suffering from mental
illness his decades of experience within
the mental health care system give him a
unique perspective
on our discussions today and it's in
that spirit i'd like to welcome mr
delgrosso to the committee and i look
forward
to his testimony thank you senator
bennett and
and now we have also mr larry fricks a
senior consultant at the national
council for behavioral health
mr fricks is also the director of the
appalachian consultant group and deputy
director of the samsa hersa
center for integrated health solutions
he will share with us his first-hand
account of recovery from mental illness
and substance abuse and
we thank you for being here at mr fricks
and
again as with the last panel uh your
statements will all be made a part of
the record in their entirety and ask you
to sum up
we'll just go down from dr hogan down in
five
six seven minutes or so so we can get to
a round of questioning
and i'll start with dr hogan who's i
read all your testimonies last night
they're very they're just excellent just
excellent every one of them
uh i remember dr ho you first you talked
about separate
but unequal mental health from
what we call regular health like yes or
no the health care system
uh dr oglenbaum can please proceed well
thank you senator harkin and uh
i just have to start as others have by
expressing appreciation on behalf of our
community uh to the
committee for focusing on this this time
it's been it's been quite a while but
the
the timing now for other reasons that
i'll explain in recent
events i think make it uh the right time
to pay this
concern and we're particularly
appreciative that this uh focus
i focus this focus happens on senator
alexander's
first uh meeting as uh as ranking member
i i would uh start my uh
by focusing on something that is subtle
and often not apparent with respect to
how mental health care is provided
and that is to say that the mental
health system started in asylums run by
states
um without the support or involvement of
the federal government anyway
and to some extent um as we
uh have focused on a movement from
asylum to community
uh the there was attention to the locus
of care
that was that was being transformed but
what escaped attention was that care in
separate
programs and systems was still separate
that is changing before our eyes right
now
and it's changing and it's accelerating
in ways that we can't even see
because of legislation that has already
been discussed first originating in this
chamber with senator wellstone and
senator dominici
to say that mental health care had to be
a part of health care
no longer separate and then second of
all
the affordable care act took
that party legislation and baked it into
all the changes in health care that are
going forward so
we are at a at a time when mental health
care is increasingly going to be part of
health care and this raises
two major questions for me one of them
is
will we take time and attention to make
sure that we get mental health right
in the mainstream of health fair of
health care we're fumbling at that
right now i want to talk a little bit
more about that and the second is
as we move away uh from the separate
system will we pay enough attention to
it
and ensure that there is sufficient
stewardship for it
in states and so on this is primarily a
state uh problem
or will we recapitulate the
institutionalization by walking in
another direction that is well intended
but that forgets the people with the
most serious needs
those seems to me are the two major uh
challenges that we face
and having said that i want to just
touch on a couple of points
briefly in that context the first of
those has to do with the imperative of
trying to figure out
how we can help primary care providers
to deliver basic mental health care
we're not asking them to do the
complicated stuff
but most primary care providers with a
little bit of help
can do an excellent job with most of the
conditions mental health conditions that
people walk into their offices
with but they can't do it on their own
they've got to have a social worker or a
nurse or somebody who can spend the time
with people their practice has got to be
paid a little
uh for that medicare still doesn't do
that
very well and we have to take steps
that are toward what's now called
integrated or collaborative care
to make sure that we provide that care
and primary care
right now more people get something for
their mental health problems in primary
care
than get it from the entire separate
mental health system
but it tends to be a day late in a
dollar short and not to be very
effective your chances of getting a
diagnosis with depression if you walk
into your gp's office
are less than 50 50 and your chances of
getting enough treatment to make a
difference
about 15 percent but with a little bit
of attention
that problem can be uh resolved
i won't comment too much on the problem
of protecting the safety net as we go
forward in this
transition but i i think what i would
say is what the
committee's attention might be focused
on is whether there are adequate
standards for mental health care not in
samhsa but in cms
as the system goes uh forward
increasingly in states right now
when you're concerned about mental
health you don't talk to the mental
health director you talk to the medicaid
director
and whether they have this on their
radar screen is a sort of a
coin flip and federal standards there
would
would help the committee has already
talked significantly about
children's issues and senator
alexander's
example of that 17 year old with an
early
a psychotic symptom that
senator murkowski also talked about is
something else that i want to comment on
we know how to address those problems
today and we do not
we know how to engage people in care
with an early psychotic
problem as we would in a sense in a
modern cancer center
family would be welcome we look at a
longitudinal plan of care we would stick
with people
to try to find something that was
acceptable to them as opposed to
waiting till they deteriorate putting in
a hospital letting them leave with a
referral to care
that is just not going to not going to
work
and um i have two other points that i've
addressed in my uh
written testimony and my time is up so i
won't comment them
other than to say i really want to
underline what senator murkowski has
said about the problem of
of suicide the administrator hyde
and the surgeon general have really
stepped up on this the department of
defense
uh and veterans affairs are are moving
on this
uh the rest of the government should pay
a little bit more attention because it's
costing us
more lives lost from suicide every week
than we lost to military suicides in the
entire last year
thank you thank you very much
dr dr hogan and now we turn to dr
biro
thank you senator harkin thank you
senator alexander
on behalf of center stone and my
colleagues in behavioral health
throughout this country i again want to
echo how much we appreciate the
attention
that community behavioral health and
mental health care in general is
receiving as a part of this hearing
you know i hope that what i share will
assist this committee truly as you seek
to gain an understanding of the
opportunities to address the gaps and
barriers
that we know currently exist in the
mental health system
it's been echoed several times this
morning that
we know recently our country absolutely
suffered
the devastating loss of 28 precious
lives
20 innocents six courageous teachers and
administrators
a mentally ill young man who did not get
the care
that he needed and his mother who did
not get the care
nor the information that she needed this
tragedy
along with those in colorado arizona
california virginia and others
have thrown a very invaluable spotlight
on community mental health mental
illness and this entire discussion
you know the working air to work in this
area to work in this area of community
mental health
is an extraordinary privilege it's
likewise
a tremendous responsibility i've been
fortunate throughout the last four
decades
to participate in our field from a
variety of perspectives as a clinician
as a critical incident responder as a
faculty member as a research
collaborator
as a patient and as a ceo i've seen
firsthand what the research shows
mental illness affects everyone and
mental health treatment
is effective community mental health
centers do a tremendous job for the
people we serve
we change and save lives helping to
build
strong healthy resilient individuals and
strong healthy resilient communities
there are however several significant
barriers and gaps in the current u.s
mental health system
that makes it difficult for our local
agencies to serve
the safety net they were intended to
serve by president kennedy more than 50
years ago
most significant among these is the
limited availability of quality mental
health services
for children and youth sadly we lack a
federal definition
of what services a community mental
health center should offer consequently
many towns and cities especially rural
ones do not have access to a continuum
of care
that covers the lifespan since 50
percent of mental illnesses
do occur do occur before the age of 14
and three out of four people
experience the initial onset of these
illnesses by the time they reach
young adulthood the lack of early
intervention can have tragic and lasting
effects
congress is encouraged to pass language
similar to that included within the
excellence in mental health act
defining that a community behavioral
health provider
must provide a full continuum of
services across
the lifespan in particular we wish to
thank senator
debbie stabenow and senator jack reed
for their tireless leadership
in this critical legislation there are
several ways as well to address the
barriers to providing quality children
services
thanks to grant funding from samhsa and
the department of education
centerstone has been able to deliver
home and school-based services
within both urban and rural areas these
programs have proven clinically
effective
and likewise offset overall educational
costs
congress could increase its support of
federal funding
to effectively deliver prevention and
early education services
congress could ensure as well that
services to children and youth
target the entire family research shows
that programs that engage the whole
family
are the most effective programs
inadequate insurance coverage
too often becomes the barrier to
engaging the entire family
incredibly not all states counties and
community mental health centers
offer formal health or offer formal
crisis services especially those
services that are delivered
seven days a week 24 hours a day 265
days a year
the excellence in mental health act
would also require the provision
of these crisis services technology
which we haven't talked very much about
this morning also prevents another
barrier
thanks to the work of the office of the
national coordinator of health i.t
in the leadership of senator shelton
whitehouse there have been tremendous
advances toward creating standardized
communication guidelines
unfortunately since community mental
health was left out of the 2009
high tech act we have not been able to
fully benefit from these advances
strong bipartisan bills in both houses
of congress
like those that have been introduced in
the prior congress by representatives
murphy
blackburn and senators white house and
collins would correct this problem
with behavioral health i.t this is what
community behavioral health would be
able to do we could effectively share
information for purposes of coordination
of care
including treatment plans with primary
care providers
we would prevent some of the drug drug
interactions that occur because of a
lack of shared information and hopefully
prevent
over-prescribing we could also
effectively track outcomes over time
there's a great need for integrating
physical and behavioral health care in
this nation
we hear a lot about america's fragmented
and broken health care system
the consequence at best is costly and at
worst
dangerous and too often deadly people
with serious mental illness on average
die 25 years earlier
than their non-mentally ill
contemporaries
is it because of their mental illness no
it's because of the impact
of their comorbid conditions diabetes
cardiovascular diseases as examples
community mental health centers are key
to improving
physical health care by simultaneously
lowering
overall health care costs our expertise
and behavior change
is part of the solution to meet the
triple aim of health care
reduce cost improved health and quality
outcomes
we're grateful that in 2009 samhsa
launched
its primary care and behavioral health
integrated care program
and since has launched 94 programs
across the country
two have happened to land at centerstone
which were very fortunate
the samhsa initiative seeks to improve
the physical health status of people
with serious mental illness
and reduce their total health care costs
by making sure services for behavioral
health and physical health
are provided at the same location
we have a substantial and complex task
before us
we cannot solve these issues alone as
providers
this is a moment this is a watershed
moment
that demands courage and action everyone
in this room
shares responsibility for the future of
community
mental health community mental health
centers
stand ready to work with you
our elected and representative officials
to make a difference
in this u.s mental health care system
thank you
thank you very much dr vero appreciate
that now mr delgrosso
welcome please proceed thank you
senators
alexander and harkin and you senator
bennett for
you've always been there for us for
mental health in our state i want to
thank you for being there
it's interesting this morning as i hear
the discussions happening around the
room
and i want to share two thoughts with
you if i might the first one is
i think you may be surprised about how
many people are watching speech c-span
today
from around the country because they're
so excited about the opportunity to
really discuss this matter
in the kind of detail that we're really
hoping for
the second part of it is i'd like to
share with you that if i could take a
video of today
and the comments that you all were
making up there and comments made down
here today
and if we could sort of encapsulate it
and play it to the public
and if that became the public message we
wouldn't have to be here today
and i think people be greatly moved by
what all was was brought here today
and what you're saying about our area of
health care and how important it is to
address it both mental health
and substance use disorder today we i've
been asked to talk about mental health
first aid there were several of you
that said tell us about what we might be
able to do to intervene
or to to order to connect earlier and
that's what i'll be sharing
but i want to make sure so i don't run
out of time to tell you that there are a
couple of things that can be done
one is is that with the shortage of
funding that has been in the area of
mental health and substance use disorder
that that funding that is available has
really been focused by on people who
already have diagnosable conditions
or are already significantly ill and we
need to ensure
that we continue to provide care in
those areas
but what we're having problems with is
when we do start doing prevention work
in both the physical health area and the
behavioral health area
often the codes and the funding are not
available and so you have to take it out
of your own pocket
in a sense as a provider or the person
themselves to try to get some of the
necessary prevention
and early intervention services and
supports that they need
to keep them from getting to that point
and this is particularly a problem in
the area of medicare
and today we haven't talked very much
about the elderly
and i think a lot of people think
because somebody's getting old
that they're going to just naturally be
depressed and it's a bad thing
but you know that's really not the
reality many people are aging
and doing well but sometimes there is
depression or have substance abuse
disorders
just like anybody else and they need the
help in the care that they can get
to be a preventative and also to get the
treatment
mental health first aid is an area in
our state that we have a great deal of
excitement about
because of couple different reasons
number one is is that we saw the
opportunity with mental health first aid
to really get out into our citizenry and
to be able to
talk about mental health itself and
increase their
literacy and their understanding and
recognition of the signs and symptoms of
common
mental health diseases like bipolar
major depression
ptsd and anxiety disorders as well as
substance use disorders
but it also provides a crisis escalation
de-escalation techniques by the people
who take the class just like physical
health
first aid helps you in order to be able
to bandage something or
to splint if there's a broken leg and
then there's a five-step
action plan to get persons in
psychiatric distress
referred to mental health providers it's
a very comprehensive program
in the wake of the serious summer that
we had we often
know about aurora and the shootings that
are there but we also had two major
fires in our state this past year that a
lot of people lost their homes there was
some loss of life
and it was one of the most depressing
summers we've had in colorado
for a long time and it's a beautiful
state to live in
and one of the things that we found is
that by using mental health first aid a
lot of people begin
reaching out more for help themselves
and to help their family members
but to understand more about what's
going on with them and what's happening
in the world around them
i'll never forget meeting one day with
senator udall and senator bennett
and talking about the issues around
mental health and senator udall looked
up and said
what we need is a program to help us to
sort of identify things for our family
members and friends
and in our churches and in our
government etc when they need help
and we said sir let us tell you about
mental health first aid and at that
point
it became a real charge for us in in
colorado
it's interesting to note that our our
mental health first aid instructors have
also done training with the governor's
cabinet
department heads and mental managers at
many
state agencies and there is a
consideration right now that all state
agency
or state employees will be will take
mental health first aid the department
of corrections does this today
and uh they have trainers and all of
their corrections officers are being
trained
i can go on and on about the number of
people who have been have received this
but i want to let you know that there's
some really great news coming out of
washington on this
that last week senator a repub
representative ron barber introduced
the mental health aid act of 2013 that's
hr 274 and this is uh
as you may know he was wounded in the
tragic incident in tucson
and mental health first aid was also
helpful in their area as they were
recovering from their tragedy there
and we have it on good authority that
there will
there is going to anticipate that
there's going to be a bill with
bipartisan support coming through the
senate
and we would really ask that you
consider supporting this
as a committee and providing the funding
that we so necessarily need in our
community
again i want to thank you so much what a
tremendous opportunity to be here today
and speak on behalf of this area of
health care thanks for your interest
thank you mr delgrosso and now we turn
to mr fricks welcome and
please proceed mr fricks
thank you chairman harkin and senator
alexander it's an
honor to be here and an honor that
um we're getting this sort of focus on
uh
those of us that experience mental
illness and addiction
um i'd like to address three topics
today
first the uh the stigma and
discrimination
that surround behavioral health
disorders
second the critical role of peer support
and a new
workforce in our country called peer
specialists that promote
recovery and third
the importance of whole health
senator harkin mind body has been huge
in my recovery
from bipolar illness
so those are the three topics i'd like
to address first of all
i i am someone who recovered from
bipolar illness
i'm also clean and sober 28 years
and i can tell you uh and my peers can
tell you that
we fight two battles we fight the
illness but we also fight the stigma
and we have a saying in our movement
what you believe about mental illness
may be more disabling than the illness
itself
and yet as a society we we
largely remain ignorant about the signs
and symptoms of mental illness
and we ignore our role as supportive
community members to help
help those of us experiencing those
illnesses
i was hospitalized three times in the
mid 80s
i fall in the category of a serious
mental illness i've
been in the back of a deputy's car it's
a very
humiliating experience i spent a day in
jail because of my psychosis
until family not available
i mean what happens is the stigma is so
significant that it
we often internalize it it takes over
our lives
it's not only the diagnosis becomes the
prognosis that your life is over as you
as you've known it
and yet today
i live a full and meaningful life i have
a wonderful
wife and a life in the north georgia
mountains
and key to that was learning
self-management skills i haven't heard
anything about self-management
those of us in recovery um we know about
self-management to stay
to stay well a peer support is huge
having somebody that you can relate to
and uh and also receiving services now
the future is mind body
i just want to say that
learning about sleep deprivation and its
role in bipolar illness was huge for my
recovery
and it was a former director of nimh
dr fred goodwin that introduced me to
that and i manage
my bipolar illness largely by managing
my sleep patterns
being very careful i fly almost every
week and i'm very careful
and so this new workforce of certified
peer specialists
in georgia for 13 years i served on the
management team for the state department
of behavioral health and developmental
disabilities
they're the fastest growing workforce in
our state we've trained nearly a
thousand
there's probably been twelve thousand
trained across the country
we focus on what we call strength based
recovery and whole health
we're able to deliver services that medi
are medicaid billable if
if the service is included in the state
plan
and research on the effectiveness of
peer specialists has been so positive
that in 2007 the centers for medicare
and medicaid services issue guidelines
for states wanting to bill
for peer support services proclaiming
them as
an evidence-based model of care so
and then research shows that we have a
unique ability as peer specialist
to connect with other peers to ignite
hope and teach skills for recovery
self-management and promoting whole
health
however i would warn you that medicaid's
focused on medical necessity
makes it tough because we we are
strength based and we look at uh
unlocking hope and managed
self-management so it's a little tough
to fund
under medical necessity so we'd like to
see more flexible funding for that
peer respite centers are springing up
across the country
staffed by us if you're feeling early
warning signs you can go in
in georgia you can we have three of them
in georgia you can spend up to seven
nights surrounded by peers and it's
keeping people out of hospitals we're
having
tremendous success in georgia we're
under a department of justice settlement
for deaths in our hospitals so this is a
service that we have that's really
starting to pay off
and then addressing this mind-body
health care there can be no health
without mental health
conversely we cannot successfully care
for people with mental health and
addiction disorders without addressing
their co-occurring physical health
disorders
research indicates that people with
severe mental illness in u.s
who are served in the public health care
system have an average life expectancy
that is 25 year
years less than the general public we've
heard that already
we're dying early 50s many of us
so i just want to thank samhsa they're
working to address this
by providing grants to community
behavioral health centers for offering
basic primary care screenings and
coordinating referrals to primary care
as part of the primary care behavioral
health integration program nurses
trained
care managers peer specialists and other
health care professionals are not
now actively working in 94 grantee sites
to screen patients
for weight gain blood lipid levels
cholesterol teach skills for whole
health self management
and more and although data is still
being collected
early results indicate that this program
has been successful
is helping people with behavioral health
conditions maintain or reduce their
weight
cholesterol blood sugar and other risk
factors for chronic disease
and i strongly urge the committee to
support this important
grant program and in closing i'd like to
say that
after nearly three decade decades of
experience in behavioral health
it's taught me that the greatest
potential for promoting recovery and
whole health
comes from within the individual and
with the support of peers family and
community
and my recommendation is to establish
and support programs that drive this
potential
putting the person at the center of all
services building on their strengths and
supports
thank you very much well thank you mr
fricks i think
your testimony really does kind of
summarize
what we're all here about here today and
that is
providing the kind of interventions and
early supports so that people can
successfully
deal with an illness just like we deal
with every other illness
and you're a prime example of that and
from my limited experience in this area
i i couldn't agree with you more that
the the the most important
element in this comes from within and
how do we build that system
pure supports so important you talked
about maybe billable
hours for providers of peer supports i
can tell you that it's
so extremely important
that self-management skills
need to be taught a lot of times this
doesn't come from just a drug
and i think it also recognizes and i was
kind of get back to
to dr vero on this also that
mental health and physical health are as
you said intricately intertwined
intricately intertwined now again at the
risk of practicing medicine without a
license
but i've been involved in this for
almost 30 years now from this standpoint
this committee and my other
committee that i think we have adequate
more than adequate data to show that so
many physiological
conditions have their genesis in
psychological conditions
and yet we always attempt to just treat
the physiological condition
and sometimes that makes it even worse
i i'm just i had to hear we had a
hearing on this
last year on pain and all the pain
clinics that have come up
all over mary they're treating pain
yeah we had one witness a very
distinguished doctor
written a lot of books about this so
that not not everything you can't make
everything just
total but for the vast majority of
of these pain afflictions it has its
genesis within psychological problems
anxiety stress
things like that that manifest itself in
pain
yet people go to pain clinics to get a
shot or to get some kind of medicine
or to get a back operation or something
like that that
may not be warranted again i i'm always
cautious to say that
this is it's not 100
i'm just saying that the vast majority
of this and i i just don't think we
recognize that
and this intricately intertwined
between mental health and and physical
health well i took a lot of my time
talking and i shouldn't
but i want to start with dr hogan
you talked about getting it right
primary care providers providing mental
health care
moving from a separate system tell me
about the affordable
the accountable care organizations now
that are springing up they're going to
have the guidelines you see
for what these entities have to provide
but i don't think we have any kind of
instructions to them and is that what
you're suggesting is that we need to
instruct these
accountable care organizations that they
also need to
structure this they need to structure it
absolutely they'll learn this sooner or
later well we can't
needle exac exactly so for example
if you have diabetes or hypertension
or cancer or these other major medical
problems
and you also have depression your total
medical costs are going to go up
somewhere between 50 and 75 percent
and if you treat the depression it
allows the person
as larry was saying to be an active
player in the management of their whole
health and so it but you can't hope
that the depression goes away you
actually have to diagnose it you have to
provide a little treatment
for it but the data shows that a
relatively small investment
in providing that mental health care in
that primary care setting or it might be
in the context of an aco
is going to reduce total costs because
people are going to be better able to
take care of themselves
now doctor bureau you mentioned that
also in your testimony about
the affordable care act for accountable
care organizations do you have any
elaboration on what dr hogan just
said i think the other element at play
are would be our expectations for
accountability so let's underscore that
we will that act will allow us to set
some clear expectations
for performance what's expected in terms
of improving those health care outcomes
in the agreement between those
accountable care organizations and the
provider in that provider system
we are now beginning to target what are
those key health care indicators on the
physical health side on the behavioral
health side
that will work together to truly improve
overall outcomes
there's a barrier of insurance coverage
i think you you mentioned that
uh in this area in this area around the
washington dc area
there are very few in network
mental health providers well i got to
look at that some time ago
and wondering why i get i've
got good coverage blue cross blue shield
and all that but i'm amazed at how few
are in the network
the more i looked at they said well the
reimbursement's not good enough
i looked at that a little bit longer and
i started thinking and looking at
the amount of support
that taxpayers through federal programs
and other programs gave these
practitioners
when they were going through medical
school or when they were then going into
their specialties
and then when they were going into their
residencies
now to be sure a lot of them accumulate
a lot of debt themselves that they're
paying back but again they
got these nice guaranteed government
loans at low interest rates
and so i'm just wondering shouldn't we
expect a little more of them
than that they just don't get reimbursed
enough by blue cross blue shield
so they're out of network and so again
as i think senator sanders said if
if you have the money and you can afford
it you're fine
but you could be actually paying a lot
in your insurance coverage
still not having the coverage for mental
health services and then you've got to
pay additional out of pocket for that
any thoughts on that mr delgrosso yes
sir thank you so much for
making that comment because it's
something that's uh what they say the
proverbial elephant that's in the room
that people don't often talk about
and it's been sort of surprising to me
how insurance companies have not been
able to somehow put together
the savings on the physical health side
if they provide more
care on the behavioral health side and
it's
uh i it may be due to the fact that
they've got short-term contracts and
don't necessarily look at the
the long run with it or whatever but i i
think that
um what we see is this brain
or the head is not connected to the body
and sometimes often is the management
and the thinking as people go forward
and so they look
at the physical health costs separately
from the behavioral
health costs and one of the one of the
real pluses for accountable care
organizations
that you are talking about is the
opportunity to bring together the
funding
to put the right service the right place
the right time
and the right cost or right payment that
might be there and it brings
all four of those pieces together where
if you're saving money on the physical
health side
by providing more behavioral health
services you can move that money over
there
as needed and vice versa so um
it's really important i think the
expectation of providing care
for people who are uninsured that has
fallen greatly on the federal government
and on our states in their indigent care
programs
and in your medicaid program so people
end up
shifting over to the public side because
they don't have the physical health
cut i mean excuse me the behavioral
health coverage on the physical health
side
it's really uh it's a quagmire
but i i think that we're on the on the
verge of making some changes that could
be very helpful for us i just told my
staff what you said we got we got to
work on this we got to make sure these
accountable care organizations
have that model and that they fully
implement that model
and hopefully we can through this
committee and through the administration
and others uh
impress upon them the necessity of doing
so
well thank you i've run way way over my
time and i apologize
senator alexander that was very
interesting thank you
mr chairman well thanks to the four of
you for
coming today and
i'd like to listen to what you have to
say so i'll ask a question
i'll ask each of you to answer if you
could if you could think of one
thing that the federal government that
we could do
to make it easier for you to spend the
money we now spend
more effectively the money we spend
primarily through the two big block
grants
and through medicaid is the way i gather
it's most of the federal money
it goes to mental health
what would be the one thing that we
could do that might make it easier for
you to do that and dr
vero if you could start and i'd like to
ask you this additional question you
mentioned
about the importance of a continuum
which makes sense for a community mental
health center now you are
you're one of the largest operators of
community mental health centers
would that be an additional cost to each
community mental health center if it did
that and if so who'd pay for that would
that
the federal government were to require
that would
how much would it cost and how much
money would we have to appropriate for
that or if we require it
without paying for it which is sometimes
what we do around here
then who would pay for it senator i want
to first start
with an acknowledgement of my early
service in tennessee
and you and your governor roll we talk
about this continuum of care
over the age span when you were governor
of tennessee
we built out a statewide
therapeutic preschool program we had
therapy preschools
in every single one of our community
mental health centers across
all 95 counties those schools were there
to deal with their most vulnerable
children with whom we were seeing
early indications of the onset of severe
mental illnesses those sed children
we've referenced several times today
so what happened very few of those
programs exist
and i can tell you we are so fortunate
center stone to still continue that
program
but it's not in the four wall classroom
any longer because that model
was no longer affordable
community mental health care has been
subjected to
a hard state of commoditization it's
just a fact
you know as we move for medicaid
programs to manage medicaid programs
we are part of the health care system
that continues to be looked at
as a commodity our services are
minimized oftentimes
to their smallest view you know
to the nickel to the you know to the
dollar to the quarter
to the nickel for differences in
choosing who the provider might be who
the
where the contract is more importantly
what the services
what that array of services are so as
that requirement dropped
with that commoditization those
preschool programs were lost
we took our preschool program and moved
into the community and here's the good
news we were only able to serve
about 48 of those children a year
because it was a high cost program and
because the managed care company
had a hard time understanding what its
role was
in addressing the health care needs of
these children while they were also
receiving vital educational services
so one of the things we need to do from
that federal level is let's remove these
barriers
that oftentimes don't allow us to bring
our systems together education criminal
justice
mental health in a cooperative way
for the sole purpose of addressing our
health care
crisis we spent too long arguing over
what part of the day
education should pay for versus what
part of the day
the managed care company or medicaid
should be paying for we have to address
those conversations
immediately if we're going to make any
difference in the conversation
that we're having that would be uh i
would like i'll ask
i'd like to work with you and i'll ask
my staff to follow up to to give
specific
examples how to do that just out of
curiosity was that part of the healthy
children initiative that we
we had initially back then yes sir well
i'll tell my wife
she'll be yeah i was 30 years ago so
we have my wife was the head of that
and the uh the deputy of that was
marguerite sally who later
uh who runs america's promise until
recently and
and headed bright horizons the uh
worksite daycare company
now we my time's about up but if there's
one thing that we could do that would
change existing law or practice to spend
the money we now spend
better and you can follow that up in
writing if you'd like to is there one
thing you'd like to briefly mention and
that's my last question
i'd like to make a recommendation that
you allow
that the services that you currently pay
for
could be opened up to provide more
services at the front end to provide
more prevention
early intervention support peer services
like what
larry was talking about a little while
ago and to
let the creativity of this country and
how we're moving forward and other areas
of health care
to also enter into behavioral health
care
and allow us to do the right thing thank
you
was there any other comment on any other
comment on this yes sir if i could add
to that we've
we keep talking about access we've
talked about the shortage of
psychiatrists especially child best
child child and adolescent psychiatrists
we've been providing tele psychiatry
services
since 2002 in the state of tennessee
those services are getting out to
counties where we can't hire
physicians where we can't draw those
physicians to maybe those more rural
areas
it is 2014 as we sit here today
we need to bring we need to align our
payment streams
with our current technology we're not
permitted in in the state of tennessee
and i know elsewhere throughout the
country
to provide telecounseling services i can
provide telepsychiatry
i can have a psychiatrist talk to a
child
and interview that child and provide
services and work alongside a
practitioner
who's sitting next to a child and do
medication management but i can't
provide
counseling services remotely through
telehealth
and get reimbursed it's 2014.
we have 12 years of experience on the
psychiatry side
and we can't seem to move out of the
current
limitations around those services thank
you mr chairman thank you
senator franken uh thank you mr chairman
thank you all
for your testimony um dr vero you you
note in your written testimony that
the number of barriers to access to
children's mental health services
specifically you recommend quote grant
funding streams that encourage existing
centers to expand their
service continuum and partner with
community organizations
i mentioned uh in the earlier
questioning that i'm introducing
a bill called the mental health
in schools act which does that exactly
probably providing grant funds for
schools to partner with mental health
centers and other community-based
organizations can you explain why this
is so important to students
and senator first let me thank you for
moving that bill forward again
this year i think it's rather i think
it's rather simple
you know we know that most of the
disorders that we see in children
um are first identified not as most of
us would believe
in the office of a pediatrician or their
family practitioner
but instead by their school teachers
some as early as their
preschool teachers who see this behavior
you know they're well trained in
normal child development they typically
know
what the what is expected of that age
group
when they see unusual and bizarre
behaviors or very very troubled children
they need to bring that to the attention
of professionals your bill is
encouraging the same thing
those teachers have the competencies to
help us
identify those children who need early
intervention we're in 160 schools
currently in tennessee
those are partnerships that work i have
licensed master's level therapists
in those schools providing the care that
you're outlining that you're addressing
we need to get we need to get
school-based services throughout the
country
i was i was just in uh in mounds view
minnesota
we had a round table there
a couple round tables but one on
specifically on this
on integrating the schools with
community
mental health and you talk
in your testimony also about how this is
really a family disease
or family matter
we had three mothers testify
whose kids were turned around
completely to the good
a woman who because the school system
had integrated their this system
with community health and they had
a a you know a mental health
partner a professional who
who took their case of a caseload of a
number of people
we had one woman there i think she was
26
she had an eight-year-old child who had
been completely turned around
three-year-old child she was a single
mom she was not
you know a wealthy woman living on fifth
avenue she was
this woman had such joy
in describing her son who had been
completely turned around he was
diagnosed i think with asperger's
and he had been unruly but once they got
a hold of it he's turned around
completely
and we had two other moms there this is
a family disease
it is i wrote two movies
in like 20 years ago on the family
disease of alcoholism
and thank you mr fricks for your
testimony congratulations on 28 years of
sobriety
when i was doing research for that i was
talking a lot to
um to to you know
rehab counselors and and
mr hogan i want dr ogan want to ask you
about this
the shocking ignorance of general
practitioners
about alcoholism when you talk about
this the teacher is
for kids in the school but the
pediatricians
what they don't know about this is
pretty remarkable
and integrated care is so important
and something we do pretty well in
minnesota and we have accountable care
organizations that were already
accountable care organizations before we
wrote accountable care organizations
into aca
and they've become a pioneer
acos what can you say about the training
of doctors
in medical school that
we should be doing that we're not doing
or have
have we gotten better at that thank you
senator
i want to just comment very briefly on
your your point about children and to
underline this in in a way that i
i think may resonate with senator harkin
because he's
been closely connected to and has
followed and helped build an
extraordinary
national program of early intervention
for young people
who have got a developmental disability
if you have got a significant
developmental disability
you're basically entitled to some
support and care for yourself and your
family
for children with these problems that
you're describing and that you know
eight-year-old who you described got
turned around
we have an average weight of nine years
until we find out about it
and these are conditions where just a
little bit of help
is going to change that young man's
trajectory possibly for the rest of his
life
so this is a profound importance and
i'll say two things with respect to your
question
around uh doctors and their in their
training and one is that
the training around uh these conditions
uh is uh you know that this there's too
much that they have to cover in medical
school and this gets short shrift
period but it's not a problem that can
be fixed by training doctors better
because the primary care doc has got
seven or eight or ten minutes
um so the the only way that this
integrated care can be delivered is if
you know one of our types is basically
parachuted into that doctor
practice and if they you know the
patient doesn't screen in the waiting
room and the doctor can then say
i i see you have concerns about you're
sleeping and you're feeling depressed
and i'd like to ask
mrs jones to come in she's an expert in
that area mrs jones can then spend the
time that it takes to talk through the
symptoms
to maybe explain the sleep issue that um
that larry described so this
these programs that go under a rubric of
collab collaborative care
that the doctor does have to change
behavior a little bit but it's got to be
a team
approach and the team approach can be
thwarted by two things one is if we take
the mental health benefit
this is i'm gonna argue in a way that
may seem reverse
if we keep the mental health benefit in
the shepherd insurance plan and only
play it
only pay it to mental health specialists
it's not going to help the primary care
doctor
but if we give it to the mainstream
insurance plan and don't
make them you know measure it did you
ask about depression
did you start people on treatment did
the did they
improve unless we do that we can't
expect results either so we're sort of
getting what we
um uh what we have designed so i'm gonna
say
that parity as important as it is is i
think less critical now than figuring
out how to
crack this uh problem of primary care
and getting support to the doctors out
there that have got eight minutes
don't have the training and don't know
how to do this stuff
okay i i would just argue that
when you know
these conditions these mental health
conditions these addiction conditions
somatize themselves in the other things
and
that that that i see a lot of nodding
that there are primary care physicians
who don't understand that
and that and don't understand
that they're seeing something that is
really
comes from something else and something
else that may be addiction or maybe
mental health i'm way over my time thank
you mr chairman
thank you senator senator warren thank
you mr chairman
and thank you all for being here today i
read your testimony uh
all of it it was a very powerful
testimony thank you very much
the the thing i drew out of the
testimony though is a part we haven't
talked about and that is that
millions of people who have serious
mental health issues are not seeking
care
and you've talked in different ways
about why that is so you're all kind of
describing a different part of the
animal that
mr frix talks about stigma and why
people
don't ask for care we talk about the the
availability of treatment
uh practitioners whether or not we've
got enough people
uh how we might deal with that with peer
specialists how we might deal with that
with community health care centers
in doctor's offices we talked a little
bit the earlier panel about research the
importance of research so we get better
treatment
how we get better outcomes at lower cost
but
but the one i wanted to focus on in this
last opportunity to talk
is about the cost to the individual i
saw the kaiser study that
that 45 of those who don't seek
care indicate that the cost
is what deters them that that all those
other things are there but they feel
like they can't afford it they can't go
out of pocket
and so what i'd like to hear from you is
about the impact about what that means
when people deny care themselves
to their children to spouses others in
their families
and just just what happens then and to
describe that either
we can talk about it in human terms we
can talk about it in financial terms
and in financial terms for the family or
for the whole system so
i'd be grateful if you talk about that
maybe mr fricks maybe you'd be
like to start
well in rural communities like mine
um it's so obvious about the stigma
because
you'll park out front if you go into the
public health
but if you got to go to mental health
you try to park around back
and so it's i mean it's just you don't
want your neighbors seeing you
going into community mental health so
when we integrate we'll we'll help fix
that everybody can go through the same
door and park in the same parking lot
but um it it's hard to explain
the devastation that occurs from the
stigma
and the active discrimination it goes
beyond just stigma
we are of all disability groups for the
least employed in the country
it bumps 90 um and
and um by the way employment is a huge
uh
factor in our recovery people that have
meaningful work
housing or discriminated against um
so it's really a lot of it is a is a um
it's a it's almost a civil rights issue
it's a it's a human rights issue
and and i am hopeful that integration
helps that and then families are really
torn apart by it too
i'm very fortunate to have had a very
supportive family
um but it if the stress and strain
economically
we'll bust up marriages um it's just
it's just a fact and so
um i mean you're right on it so
thanks for your acknowledgement of that
thank you thank you mr del grasso
larry thanks you say it so well i just
think it's interesting
that families would not hesitate
to get a family member help for an
appendicitis
or any other kind of physical health
problem they have
but often have a very difficult time
reaching out to get the physical
or the behavioral health and the
substance use disorder treatment that
they need
and the bottom line is it's often seen
as that you have a character problem
or you've got a bad mom and dad or
something along those lines rather than
the fact for many people
it's they have a brain disease there's a
lot of education yet
still to come and a lot of support that
we need at several levels for people
to be able to to move forward and raise
their hand to come out and get help
i can also say as a mental health
provider all these years
that uh we need to stick our head up a
little bit too and be proud of the fact
of the area of health care that we
provide
care in and that you know we're not an
enigma let's take the uh the
cloak off of this and let's talk about
it what it really is
and how people can recover and become uh
remarkable members of our community
with the chairman's indulgence could i
ask dr vero to
add your comments briefly on dr hogan
senator thank you for the question
and i'll answer it i think from maybe
both the human side and the financial
side
we can't afford not to treat these
illnesses that we identify
especially those that we identify early
they simply get
worse mental illness is
a systemic family disease
you know we know that when we look at
addiction disorders
in particular alcohol you know there may
be one individual in that family
with an alcohol addiction that entire
family
can pick up signs and symptoms of that
illness
and there's dysfunction throughout that
family those same things often occur
with people who have severe and
persistent mental illness
mental illness is the leading cause
of disability in the united states
that cost alone should alarm us all
and we have to start treating this on
the front end and not treating it with
disability payments
thank you thank you i'll conclude on
that same
point within at some point in the last
10 years the the total cost of society
of mental illness passed
the total cost of cancer and is running
second to heart disease but what is uh
striking about those statistics is that
while the
the cost of cancer and heart disease or
the cost of providing care
the cost of mental illness is
essentially the cost of not providing
care it's the cost of years lost
of life due to suicide of people not
being able to function
fully at uh at work of children not
graduating because
they weren't able to sit in their seat
long enough and then it escalated and
they dropped out in
uh in high school so if if we could
uh reverse this just uh a little bit and
provide
effective uh treatments maybe we could
slip back from number two to number
three again
thank you very much thank you mr
chairman thank you senator warren
well i i just want to thank this panel
very very much
both for the work you do but for the
testimony you've offered here today
um again uh
there was a reason why we wanted to
start off our this
this congress and why i wanted to start
off this congress with this kind of
hearing in this committee
was simply for the reasons that many of
you expressed in one way or the other
and that is we can't really get a
a handle on a
a health care system
in america until we get a handle on
integrating mental health
with physical health and i would lean a
little bit more towards mr frick's
side on looking at this mind-body
connection
and and i know dr hogan
i i i appreciate that not every primary
care practitioner you know they've got
eight or nine 10 minutes
they've got to remember a lot of stuff
from medical school and their residency
training
but it does seem to me that systems
have to be built where you have a
collaboration i have seen these
yes they're around the country where if
you go in
and you have hopefully electronic
records
and you have some ailment that you have
come in to
see a primary care practitioner about
whether it's in a community health
center or someplace else
private practice that there's a
collaboration
with the primary care physician maybe a
physical therapist a psychiatrist or
psychologist or maybe both
to take a look what really is affecting
this person
is it a physical element that requires
some physical intervention or is it a
physical element that's
been manifested because of a
psychological problem that needs to be
attended to
or is it something else that needs is is
this something where a
a a qualified therapist could work with
them and their family
to take care of rather than thinking
there has to be some prescription for
some medicine filled out to go to the
drugstore to get
so it just seems to me as we're moving
ahead with
this affordable care act and this new
regime
with all the exchanges and everything we
have an opportunity i hope
and with it with the expansion of the
community health centers around america
and that's for dr vero i'm going to
we're going to be in touch with you more
about what you've done in tennessee um
because i think there's some there's a
model there for
what we're going to do with community
health centers in the future
and how they're integrated into this
system
so that's why i i i i think this hearing
is so important because
you dr hogan just said that that the
cost of
mental illness now outstrip the cost of
cancer in our country
and yet we just don't pay attention to
it so
hopefully this will set the stage for a
lot of good bipartisan work and
integration here of this committee
looking at what we need to do
to to provide this sort of new
integrated model
uh in this new healthcare regime that we
seem to be
embarked upon here sometime in the in
this
in the near future so i thank you very
much and uh and
uh we will i'm certain our staffs or us
will be in touch with you
as we move along here for further
enlightenment and further
suggestions uh and um
recommendations you might have oh yes
certainly senator alexander i want to
thank
senator harkin for this and i want to
thank the witnesses for coming you've
made some very useful
suggestions and i look forward to
following up if i may
say it this way this is a committee on
which we can have some fairly profound
differences of opinion
when we're talking about new laws new
spending
new policies but it seems to me
that a lot of what we fail to do in the
here in the federal government is look
at what we're already doing
and as people who are doing it how can
we take
the programs that we've got and the
money that we've got and make it easier
for
you to do what you need to do and you've
given us a long list of things today
that that you have suggested that
what would improve your ability to
identify who needs help and identify the
person to provide the help
so while we may argue about some things
there's no need to argue about those
things we can work together on those
things
and i would look forward very much to
that opportunity and i'll look
forward specific to your specific
suggestions about the
laws regulations and practices that you
think we ought to change
uh and i'll work with senator harkin and
see if we can do this in a bipartisan
way thank you very much senator
alexander thank you i request that the
record remain open for 10 days for
members to submit statements and submit
additional questions for the record
without this again thank you all very
much the committee will stand adjourned